ينضم الان الينا من خان يونس الصحفي
اسماعيل ابو عمر اذا الاتصالات اسماعيل
منقطعه بشكل كبير بالانترنت ربما هناك
محاولات في بعض الاماكن ما الذي يمكن قوله
يعني يهم جدا ان نسمع شهاداتكم انتم
الموجودين على الارض تفضل
اسماعيل يعني الاتصالات منذ بدايه الحرب
وحتى هذه اللحظه تاتي ولكن بشكل ضعيف جدا
جدا وهذا يؤثر بالتاكيد على عمليه التواصل
ما بين المواطنين خاصه نتحدث بان قطاع غزه
تم تقسيمه الى اكثر من قسم في ظل الحصار
الاسرائيلي والتوغل الاسرائيلي من قبل
اليات الاحتلال وقطع اوصال المناطق في
قطاع غزه هناك جزء في المناطق الشماليه
وجزء في المناطق الجنوبيه هناك نازحون من
المناطق الشماليه باتجاه المناطق الجنوبيه
وهذا بالتاكيد يؤثر على عمليه التواصل كما
تحدثنا انقطاع الاتصالات في هذه اللحظات
في هذه الظروف الصعبه هناك شهداء يعني
يرتقون في المناطق الشم ماليه اهاليهم
وذويهم وذويهم موجودون في منطقه رفح او
منطقه خانيونس وهناك ايضا العكس شهداء في
المناطق الجنوبيه ذووهم ايضا متواجدون في
مناطق الشماليه كل هذا يعني ياتي في ظل
انقطاع الاتصالات يصعب من حاله التواصل
حتى معرفه المعلومات الكافيه والوافل عن
ذويهم والاطمئنان على حالاتهم و وصحتهم
وظروفهم الصحيه وظروفهم المعيشيه ايضا كل
هذا يعني يصعب في مثل هذه الاوقات التي تق
فيه الاتصالات الانترنت طبعا في هذه
اللحظات يعني ينقطع ايام ومن ثم يعود
بالتدريج ولكن يعود بشكل ضعيف جدا جدا
وهذا ايضا يؤثر ايضا على المواطنين خاصه
تتحدث بان عدد قليل من المواطنين الذين
يعني يستطيعون الوصول الى شبكات الانترنت
في مثل هذه الظروف الصعبه بطرق ملتويه
وطرق صعبه جدا يعاني فيها ويقاسي فيها
سواء الصحفيون والنشطاء وكذلك الاهالي من
اجل الوصول الى شبكات الانترنت في مثل هذه
الاوقات الصعبه اذا الاوضاع ماساويه
والظروف ماساويه وانقطاع الاتصالات يزيد
حاله الماساه لد ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
والمعاناه لد ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني حتى
يطمئنوا على ذويهم وابنائهم في مناطق
مختلفه من قطاع غزه هناك تصلنا اتصالات
احيانا من خارج قطاع غزه يعني يريدون ان
يطمئنوا على اهلهم في في داخل قطاع غزه
يعني قبل قبل قليل كان هناك اتصال يعني
وردني من من احدى احد المواطنين وقال انه
يريد ان يوصل رساله بان اسم احد المصابين
قد ورد في كشوفات السفر في هذه الليله
وعلى ما يبدو ان صاحب هذا الاسم لا يتوفر
لديه انترنت ولا ولا يتوفر لديه ايضا
اتصال في ظل انقطاع
الاتصالات وهذا يصعب من حاله وصول هذه
الحاله الى معبر رفح في في حين ان موعد
سفر في هذا الصباح الساعه السابعه صباحا
وكذلك مما يصعب الامر اكثر ر ان الكشوفات
التي تاتي الى الجانب الفلسطيني موافقه
لسفر هؤلاء سواء كانوا من اصحاب الجوازات
الاجنبيه او حتى من الجرحى تاتي هذه
الكشوفات متاخره تقريبا في منتصف الليل
وبالتاكيد في هذه الساعه يكون هناك يعني
المواطنون في اكيد موقف صعب اسماعيل يعني
يكون اسمك على اللائحه ولا تستطيع ان تصل
للمكان المحدد طيب ما الذي يحدث اذا مثلا
كان يفترض ان يغادر هذا الصباح ولم يغادر
ولكن اسمه اللائحه هل يستطيع ان يغادر
فيما بعد
ا يحتاج الامر الى تنسيق جديد مع الجانب
المصري وكذلك الجانب الفلسطيني من اجل ان
يدرج اسمه مره اخرى في مثل هذه الكشوفات
هناك حاله مرونه من الجانب الفلسطيني لكن
الامر يصعب اكثر في في في الجوانب الاخرى
لان نتحدث بان بعض الاسماء تحتاج الى
تنسيق وتحتاج الى موافقه ايضا من اجل خروج
كثير من الحالات التي وصلت الى المعبر
المصري تم ارجاعها واعادتها الى قطاع غزه
بسبب يعني بعض الظروف وكذلك
ال الموافقه على هذه الاسماء اما بالرفض
او اما بالايجاب في حال تمت الموافقه يتم
السماح له بالمغادره في حال لم تتم
الموافقه يعود الى ادراجه الى قطاع غزه
كثير من الحالات يعني يعني شاهدناها
وعيناها في قطاع غزه بمثل هذه الظروف وفي
غالب الا الاحوال يتم تجديد عملي التنسيق
من قبل الجانب الفلسطيني مع هذم الحالات
ويع مره اخرى عبر بلا شك يعني ومن يوضع
اسمه اصلا على اللائحه يكون في حاجه ماسه
فعلا للانتقال وهذا الامر انه لا يعني
يكون اسمه على اللائحه ولكن لا يتم ايصال
المعلومه له بسبب هذا الوضع الانساني على
العموم اسماعيل ابو عمر اشكر